[Music]
for most
jobs it's understood that you can be
fired whether for crime
incompetence or just poor performance
but what if your job happens to be the
most powerful position
in the country or the world that's where
impeachment comes in impeachment isn't
the same as
actually removing someone from office
like an indictment in criminal court
it's only the formal accusation
that launches a trial which could end in
conviction
or acquittal originating in the united
kingdom
impeachment allowed parliament to vote
for removing
a government official from office even
without the king's consent
although this was an important check on
royal power
the king couldn't be impeached because
the monarch was considered the source of
all government power
but for the founders of the american
republic there was no higher authority
beyond the people themselves and so
impeachment was adopted in the united
states
as a power of congress applying to any
civil officers
up to and including the president
although
demands for impeachment can come from
any members of the public
only the house of representatives has
the power to actually
initiate the process it begins by
referring the matter to a committee
usually the house committee on rules and
the house committee on the judiciary
these committees review the accusations
examine the evidence
and issue a recommendation if they find
sufficient grounds to proceed the house
holds a separate vote
on each of the specific charges known as
articles of impeachment if one or more
passes by a simple majority the official
is impeached
and the stage is set for trial the
actual trial that follows
impeachment is held in the senate
selected members of the house
known as managers act as the prosecution
while the impeached official and their
lawyers present their defense
the senate acts as both judge and jury
conducting the trial and deliberating
after hearing
all the arguments if it's the president
or vice president being impeached
the chief justice of the supreme court
presides
a conviction requires a super majority
of two-thirds and results in automatic
removal from power
depending on the original charges it can
also disqualify them
from holding office in the future and
open them to standard criminal
prosecution
so what exactly can get someone
impeached
that's a bit more complicated unlike in
the united kingdom
impeachment in the u.s pits an elected
legislature
against other democratically elected
members of government
therefore to prevent the process from
being used as a political weapon the
constitution specifies that an official
can only be impeached
for treason bribery or other high crimes
and misdemeanors
that still leaves a lot of room for
interpretation
not to mention politics and many
impeachment trials
have split along partisan lines but the
process
is generally understood to be reserved
for serious
abuses of power the first official to be
impeached
was tennessee senator william blunt in
for conspiring with britain to seize the
spanish colony
of louisiana since then the house has
launched impeachment investigations
about 60 times but only 19
have led to actual impeachment
proceedings
the eight cases that ended in a
conviction and removal from office
were all federal judges and impeachment
of a sitting president
is even more rare andrew johnson was
impeached in 1868
for attempting to replace secretary of
war edwin stanton
without consulting the senate over a
century later
bill clinton was impeached for making
false statements under oath
during a sexual harassment trial both
were ultimately
acquitted when the senate's votes to
convict fell
short of the required two-thirds
majority
and contrary to popular belief richard
nixon was never
actually impeached for the watergate
scandal he resigned before it could
happen
knowing he would almost certainly be
convicted
theoretically the u.s government is
already designed to prevent abuses of
power
limiting different branches through a
system of checks and balances
term limits and free elections but
impeachment
can be seen as an emergency break for
when these safeguards
fail
ted ed is a non-profit if you value our
work please consider supporting it on
[Music]
patreon.com
bye